At this point, hopefully you feel like you can attack a new,
big investigation, bring it within the scope of a statistical inference problem,
and then apply iterations of the QMV process to gradually hone a solution.
You've seen a taste of what model building and
data analysis problems looks like in the real world.
And how it is a continual process of investigation, finding results and
then proposing new lines of investigation based upon those results.
Sometimes retrying and adjusting previous decisions.
Specifically we get the process going by iterating on an initial question,
until we arrive at answers to the following.
What metric will we be using to capture the phenomenon?
What statistical inference problem will we be examining?
What features will inform the inference problem?
Once we've determined how to measure the problem, as well as what form of
question we'll be answering, we enter the modeling phase,
in which we choose a method for answering this question.
Ideally, this method should take advantage of any
structure within the data that achieves the maximum effectiveness.
Lastly, once we've built a model.
We evaluate how good the model is at generalizing to the wider phenomenon in
the validation phase.